six to play
booker this is for the win got it
wow
[Applause]
he's really gifted 41st overall tim
conley
and what about that block scion from the
league side hey that'll get them
off they're up on their feet hey can
somebody from the 15th roll throw that
ball back on the sport please
[Applause]
wow the big man slings it up
and slings it in here we go who's going
to take this shot to try to tie her win
outside to bogey he's crowded
[Applause]
foggy struggling throughout the night
takes on a double team and hits a thumb
to give utah the win westbrook left wide
open had to kick it out
picked off here's bradley ahead of the
field
lebron here not getting in the dark
contest but he says listen all-star week
is only a couple days away
buzzer beater you see patty trying to
contest that shot from behind to swipe
it over the top
oh my goodness the bar derozan with
a vicious slam they might have to put
in the country protocol
but that was as bad
and as filthy as it gets marcus smart's
going to stay up high
taking anybody coming to the ball here
he's on the line anani got it off and it
goes oh gianna nobody buries a triple
at the buzzer big shot what a moment
for o.g ananovi potentially
saving toronto season their first win of
this series
six to play
booker this is for the win got it
[Applause]
wow that is good
for sure what a shot
devin booker today
puts the suns now 3 and 0
in the bubble they are learning a lot in
a short while here
finney smith the inbound back to doncic
dodges pulls up three-pointer bang
bang it's good doncic wins the game
at the buzzer we are witnessing the next
great star in the nba in his first
playoff series
clock at seven working against butler
got downhill
couldn't punch it bam says get it out of
here
out of bio sky high
with the block and rejection 2.1 seconds
remaining
denver foul to give jokic trying to
disrupt rondo he puts it in here's davis
4-3 in the win
oh it's good anthony davis has
won it for the lakers
[Applause]
in the clutch delivers the bomb
great defense by the nuggets just
outstanding
offense by anthony davis who's made
back-to-back
huge threes here in this fourth quarter
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher